so guys my name is trying to welcome to
another camera angle also the game
engine series today I thought that we
would do something a little bit
different I feel like we've just been
who's been making this game engine has
been all serious serious serious and I
sat down today and I was like do I even
want to do this and the answer was last
time I was able to show you what the
hazel community was able to make check
out that video if you haven't already
and today what I thought we would do is
we will try and make something ourselves
and I would show you just a few of the
other things that have happened
throughout the week as you can see I'm
in my cozy jumper yet again and what
we're gonna do is dive in and see if we
can make something some sort of game
some kind of rendering test let's take a
look so in all seriousness the first
thing that I wanted to show you guys was
this little Trello board that I made
this is something that will hopefully
shed a little bit of light into what is
happening with hazel right now stuff
that we've planned issues that we know
affect the engine all of that kind of
stuff to go to it you can simply go to
hazel engine comm slash issues and that
will actually take you to this Trello
board it's public you should be able to
see it and you can even leave comments
please read this kind of welcome section
and a kind of description of what all
the labels do but otherwise we just have
this little list that I made just then
in around five minutes so of course it's
gonna I'm gonna keep adding stuff to it
and it's going to change probably a lot
now one more thing that I actually
wanted to add before I start recording
this video and totally forgot was if
there are issues that you want to report
I've got this kind of report section
maybe write a comment over here I can
make it into like an actual known issue
card and stuff like that and if you have
also kind of feature requests will say
or something like that I'll just write
ideas and I'll probably move this over
into another list which I'll call I
don't know maybe like community or
something like that and then you guys
can just go nuts and put ideas and stuff
that you want to see all of that stuff
just under this card here but in general
you can see that we're currently working
on 2d rendering the cards kind of
explain what everything means and I will
probably end up adding in more detailed
description as well but this is kind of
what we're what we're looking at
everything else is obviously stuff that
I've thought about or considered in one
way or another and then texture atlases
is kind of the next big feature that
were
going to be working on in 2d rendering
now this point is probably worth saying
that the reason why I'm making this
little game slash and I don't even know
what to call it but the reason why I'm
making this thing in hazel today and why
I decided to do this was because things
like texture Alice is well they require
textures we need to have some kind of I
want to have something that is actually
in hazel as distributed I guess as part
of this hazel repository something that
we've just put together really quickly
that will actually be able to
demonstrate all these features and
whilst that kind of game that we talked
about in a lot in the last episode there
was made by the community is great and
all I really want to keep that as like a
standalone game and that'll be like a
project that uses hazel but then as
we're developing hazel I also want to
have something kind of internal to the
engine so hopefully that clears it up a
little bit as for what we're going to
make let's take a look at what we have
right now in hazel what we have is
inside the sandbox class we have this
kind of demo of using these various
things and that's fine I'm actually
going to continue writing this stuff
right here in the sandbox 2d class
because the sandbox 2d class it's a 2d
sandbox it's meant for that stuff but
the first thing I'm going to do is
probably well there's it there's a few
ideas that I had just before this video
began what I wanted to do was
essentially make some kind of tile based
like 2d top-down RPG roguelike whatever
style environment so we want to probably
have like some dirt textures I guess we
probably want some way to also define
what a level looks like rather than
being completely random but I want
probably like at least 10 also different
textures so that we can eventually put
them into a texture Atlas or just test
out you know rendering ten different
textures inside the batch renderer
individually I also want to distress
test the renderer in general and I
thought what better way to do that than
to use some kind of particle system now
I wrote a particle system in an hour
it's called one our particle system I'll
link the video over there in the top
right corner if you guys haven't seen
that check it out
now that was completely standalone to
hazel it was just using my OpenGL kind
of library so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna copy this as best as we can
we're going to implement it into the
batch renderer and we're gonna see if it
can actually handle that so that's the
first thing that I want to do let's go
ahead and do that and we
gonna do it completely live so we do
have some randomization here but in
general I think the particle system is
fairly straightforward let's go ahead
and try and just copy it kind of as is
and then we'll see if we can just like
make it work a little bit better so in
sandbox sauce I'm doing this all in
sandbox because when the time comes to
write a particle system in hazel is
going to be very different
oops I just tried to paste in the source
code into the name of the file that's
all good when the time actually comes to
write a particle system in hazel it's
obviously going to be very different
than this little particle system that I
wrote in one hour and I probably call a
particle system instead of particle
sometimes when I'm talking it's
difficult to do anything all right so
the CBP file we're going to go ahead and
grab the entire CPP file now at the
moment this kind of just deploys like a
whole bunch of particles at the mouse
cursor I guess that's a pretty cool way
of doing things and I might actually
continue to do that so let's include
hazel instead of like gel core and all
of that stuff we don't need to do things
like load shaders we don't really need
to do a lot I think we'll do hazel time
step obviously on render takes in an
orthographic camera sure we'll kind of
keep it I don't want to spend today
writing some kind of particle system so
we will keep it fairly fairly like
similar to the original kind of one
except for the old all the places where
it's different so we use some
randomizations and I think yeah we
probably want to grab the random class
as well because I don't want to bloat
the code of you know this too much I'm
just going to paste the class into
whoops I'm just gonna paste the class
right over here into the top of this
file will include random and then the we
want is like some static stuff I guess
we probably should grab that as well
shouldn't we because we had that stuff
in the original file so I'll just take
this stuff and I will paste it over here
all right so we have this random now
this random class that we can use hazel
orthographic camera replaces this stuff
now this is us creating like a vertex
arrays and various particles like
shaders and stuff like that we don't
really need any of that so I'm just
going to delete that and we don't need
this use program really all we need to
do on in on render is rendered
articles and since we already have a
renderer we can just use our existing
renderer so you can see that if I copy
this stuff this is really what we use to
render so let's paste it over here and
I'm gonna try and quickly like translate
this code that I've haven't actually
looked at before today so hopefully
won't take too long
I should probably stop talking okay so
we have a transform oh well we doing one
oh yeah we were doing one drop call per
particle okay
well that that's gonna be different so
we don't have a transform anymore but
what we do do is we do probably a rotate
either a rotated or a non rotated quad
depending on the rotation they are
different kind of yeah okay so what I'll
do is I'll say if particle dot rotation
is not zero so if I mean realistically
there pretty much all of them are going
to be rotated so I probably just skip
this if check for every single thing and
just draw a rotated quad if it comes out
of zero zero is going to be fairly
unlikely I think so we're just going to
do a draw rotated quad here we're going
to want to take in the particle
positions which we can just I think we
can just give it a 2d position like this
particle position then we want a
rotation which is going to be this is
the size I get cool so the size is just
let's say size size I think and then the
rotation is Park rotation now this is
important because over here I'm clearly
giving it the rotation in degrees I
think right wait why is it minus 45
oh this was an hour hour test that's
right I thought anyway doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I think so particle
rotation here
that's probably I'm not sure if that's
oh well yeah it's in radians so it looks
like does our API support radians see
this is why it's really nice to just do
tests and stuff to make sure that
everything's all right because obviously
like we I think I've mentioned this
before but this should always be in
radians because if you want to convert
to radians that should be like if you if
you want to store degrees then you want
that to be like a kind of client based
thing you don't want to always force the
renderer to have to do conversions for
you because that's going to slow things
down
if you
sword in radians to begin with because
then you'll have to convert to degrees
to give it to the renderer which is
going to convert into radians anyway
which is silly and we're trying our best
here not to be silly so this does
rotation yeah it does do Jill I'm right
here so this is very bad I know I did
that and I know that I probably
shouldn't have that's why we had minus
45 there but it's okay
we'll convert this we'll make sure we're
not doing any kind of conversion here
into radians whatsoever so we were doing
one over here as well and I'll write a
little note in the comment just so that
it's super clear that this is like
rotations rotation is in radians okay
just just as like a little note so that
we know that we are in fact dealing with
radians and since we did a kind of test
rotate roadheader quads here I will
actually do a little conversion into
radians here just so that we don't break
our existing code base so rotation I
guess that was in yeah well it was it
was always in degrees so now we're
converting into radians okay cool that
stuff is done now the next thing I want
to do is I want to go back to my
particle system and so we've got our
size we'll put in the particle rotation
which is just a particle dot rotation
and this is the color so the color we
used was particle shader color and that
was just a GL n value pointer that was
just our color really so I can probably
grab that and just stick that in here
and I think that's it so we're drawing a
rotated quad at the correct position
with the right size with the correct
rotation and with the correct color so
we didn't this this particle system
didn't support textures or anything so
that's fine if it did it wouldn't really
be an issue but basically all of that
stuff is gone now the next step is this
kind of begin scene and scene so
obviously we'll do that for the entire
like particle pool so we'll do just this
is just camera so you can see it
actually integrates kind of nicely with
our API here and this is good because
you know which one and test out the
render a 2d API and it's not bad I guess
all right and then in color we had color
a times life I don't remember why that
was there but it was commented out so
guess we'll leave it as is but that's I
think that's it so that's now converted
you can see it should compile if I hit
control
seven to just compile the file yep we're
good I think yep we're good okay so now
if we go back to sandbox 2d let's
actually use this particle system so
I'll include it we'll do include
particle system particle system 2h and
then I will just have a little particle
system here and now I'm actually going
to pop over through my code to see to
the one our particle system repository
to see how I actually used this so I
think it was here right okay we
basically predefined a certain particle
and it was called M particle so that was
obsessed random so that was I think M
particle was so we had it was yeah it's
probably a particle props thing and then
but that's a particle system - what did
I actually want to open this is all
going wrong here it is sandbox layer so
sandbox layer yeah so it had this
particle props which was a particle is a
properties thing so let's grab that and
then we'll come over here and we'll also
put that in here so we have a particle
as well and then we'll initialize it
with just the same stuff here because
again I don't want to spend too much
time on this and we've already got some
code for us so over here and on attach
I'm going to you know this is our
particle it's pretty clear that it's a
particle we don't really need a comment
for that and then coming down here I
guess what we did was okay so we have
and again this even uses hazel like key
code so it's super easy to implement so
we have so we did particle system on
update on render and we had a little bit
of input stuff going on in on update
that should be fairly easy to replicate
so if we go back to here and look at our
on update function let's draw our scene
first and then after we do end scene and
this is kind of like a little scope for
that let's come over here and let's do
so this will be hazel input is mouse
button pressed
hazel input get Mouse position so
luckily this API is pretty much
identical
hazel application get window get with
that it actually is identical I did base
off that OpenGL library Oh hazel
obviously so that that helps camera
control get bounds that's something that
we don't have that's something that I
think I had to add during I don't know
just during the development of that
because we need to know the bounds of
our cameras so that we can actually draw
the particles or actually emit the
particles from the correct space so
let's go back into this one our particle
system and then we'll go into I guess
core source and then let's go to jail
core core maybe lots of core everywhere
and then where do we have our camera we
don't have a camera here let's just type
in let's try and search for camera in
this repository and we'll see what the
where is it okay so it's an util
orthographic camera control it that
makes sense so if we look at the header
file I guess here are our bounds so we
have this thing called struct
orthographic camera bounds and then we
have get bounce which returns bounds
okay let's quickly integrate these
bounds into our camera because I think
in general it's useful to actually know
what we're dealing with as far as bounds
go and I guess this is something that
could be inside the orthographic camera
class itself not necessarily the
controller class so if we go back out
here I mean we did actually have this
inside orthographic camera controller
but I think that was only because yeah
why did we decide to put it in
controller maybe maybe we do want to
have it in control of them I don't know
passed me seems to have made that
decision and since we have a controller
here I'm gonna leave it here the reason
I wasn't sure was because it might
actually help to know the bounds of the
camera itself but I don't know that
might again that might have some
performance implications and if we just
want a quick and dirty performance
camera we don't want to be continually
recalculating the balance whereas for a
camera controller that would be
necessary so like as in not necessary
but that probably is permissible so here
we have bound here I could see the way
I've implemented this is it's very
reliant on you know doing extra
calculations and stuff so I think we had
yeah camera aspect ratio zoom level
stuff like that whereas that's what
bounds becomes so we're just kind of
it's not really a huge deal in terms of
performance because we're just we're
just changing where we're storing this
stuff but you know it might be something
that we don't want to have inside our
camera class for all cases because again
that kind of fact that default like
orthographic camera class is just
supposed to be a container
data which is like the you know the
matrix of the camera and stuff like that
okay so let's see so bounds yeah bounds
needs to always get get updated I
probably should just steal this
orthographic camera controlled so I
think it's better than ours but on mouse
scrolled I think that was that so yeah
we just update the bounds here I think
before we do the cert projection
probably yeah and then we set the
projection and then it's the same bounds
update before we set projection so
projection I believe should be based off
of the bounds that's probably the whole
point of this so if we scroll up a
little bit and let me just I'll search
for balance here just to make sure we're
not missing anything no we're really not
so where does it set the projection so
we call can our camera set projection
and then we do it up based off the
balance so yeah
my mistake I thought set projection was
something in this class let's just set
it to that okay cool so what kind of
adding in like a little middleman just
so that we can retrieve that middleman
and then be able to figure out the
bounds of the camera really easily when
we need to and we need to in certain
situations where we for example want to
emit particles in camera space so let's
kind of take this and well it's not
really oh it's not really about camera
space it's more about just the fact that
remember we want to emit particles from
the mouse pointer but the mouse pointer
is obviously relative to the window
whereas we want to emit the particles
into world space so this is going to
account for like the camera zoom and
everything else which is going to be
super important now I'm going to go back
to the sandbox 2d class and fix
everything up I was gonna say but it
looks like everything works so based on
this code that I just slapped in does
hazel now have a little bit of a
particle system we will find out by
hitting f5
okay so first step is nothing renders
and then also the particles don't render
oh I was just zoomed in I need to update
the balance probably there okay so our
particles do in fact render and you can
see they are in camera space if I make
this fullscreen and I move around I can
just generate these kind of orange
particles wherever the mouse cursor is
now they're happening behind these which
might be fine might not be fine
we are always drawing with with depth
testing enabled and we are actually
using the zetas buffer to figure out
positions like this
so because of that like again it might
be worth rendering particles in this
example with depth testing off just so
they always render on top as long as we
ran it them last but that's just the way
it is I guess so what is rendering on
top exactly this stuff and why is it
rendering on top
I think we're rendering with a set of
zero which is probably fine
realistically I mean what we could do if
we wanted to sink it a little bit back
you can see that well the first thing I
probably want to check is where we
rendering these particles so we're just
doing position and position does
position particle props position so
there's no Zed or anything like that
here is there if we go back to sandbox
2d let's say the position is zero zero
as a 2d position okay so what we could
do is realistically if we wanted them to
really be in front is we could come over
here into the rendering code and then
just set their position which is over
here to basically be well let's do this
we'll do
GLM effect three position equals and
we'll take the particle position we'll
place it without position we'll set it
to be there's no easy way I think to do
this but dot X dot Y and then we can you
know choose to for example bring it
forward or whatever so that the Zed is a
little bit higher and therefore it
should be on top and you can see now if
I rerun this the particles are on top so
that's just something that we could do
if we wanted to actually do this and the
cool thing is if you look at the render
or 2d stats that we have here we have
405 quads three draw calls but what what
happens when I move this around so you
can see we're up to like 600 and then
obviously as they fade away we go down
to 405 so that's basically what's
happening we're rendering about 250 or
so quads we should be able to massively
increase that though and we can do that
by first of all making sure that the
life is a little bit more than it is
here so a lifetime at the MoMA is one
second let's make it like five seconds
and then also instead of emitting like
how many do we do we do five like
particular we can do like 50 so ten
times more now this probably gonna be a
lot of particles let's be honest I did
just jam up the life by five times and
also the
actual you know yep here it is so here
experiencing a little bit of framerate
here and they don't look like they're
lasting very long they're not lasting
very long because the particle pool is
only a thousand
so actually realistically we are only
able to render a thousand at a time
which is not going to be enough so if we
go into particle particle system dot H
and we take a look at the particle pool
of $9.99 is the size we probably want to
add a parameter over here particle
system you into 32 T max particles and
then this is going to be important
because what it's going to do is it's
going to when we create this it's going
to resize it to the max particles and
then we also want to set pull index to
be basically max particles minus 1 and
then I think everything else should
definitely not be dependent on that
1,000 figure and it doesn't look like it
is so pool index will set to like a zero
that gets set automatically in fact we
well I mean we don't need to initialize
it here because the constructor is
taking care of that obviously and then
when we create this so I mean at the
moment like we can give it a default
value if we want that might be nice so
let's set this to like I don't know
let's do a hundred thousand so that's a
hundred thousand particles so that
should be that should be not bad I think
we can do a hundred thousand draw calls
or rather a hundred thousand particles
so yeah this is definitely a lot more
and you can see those quads are going up
our frame rates going down there's a few
things we can do about that we can run
this in release mode but realistically I
think this is going to be probably
bottlenecked by the way this particle
system is written because as you can see
it just has a particle with a whole
bunch of data in it and then it's just
got like an array of that so our
daughter is extremely fragmented why not
you know we're not kind of keeping it
all in one place although you can see
that in release mode we really don't
have a particle we don't really have a
problem and you can see they're all kind
of here we have a whole bunch of
particles I don't know what our
performance is it doesn't say but if I
just keep doing this you can see we're
okay
we kind of know 10,000 quads yeah it's
kind of hard to draw more than I guess
13,000 quads because that's just the
rate at which particles are being
generated and then reused in the pool
but you can see we do indeed have quite
a lot of particles and you know this is
felt fairly smooth even with the like
terrible use of memory inside our
particle system so that is that one more
thing I quickly wanted to mention as
well as we had this problem where of
course we open this and we see nothing
and we have to kind of zoom out and then
the camera starts working again
this is one of those things that is very
easy to miss in C++ but you can see that
what we're doing here is where it looks
like we're initializing the bounds first
with the correct data and then we're
actually giving it to the camera but
what's happening is the camera is being
is actually being initialized first with
the wrong bounds with the uninitialized
bounds and then the bounds are being
initialized and that's because if we
look at the header file the order in
which we've defined them in is like this
the camera first then the bounds this is
the initialization order not whatever
you've put over here so if we simply
switch these two so we do the bounds
first then the camera if we hit our v we
should be absolutely perfect and you can
see from the very first frame everything
is correct so anyway I hope you guys
enjoy this little kind of different type
of video I guess what we're gonna do
next time and I am gonna make one of
these videos like I'm not gonna make you
guys wait for another week and we'll
just do this again I'm gonna make a
video in a few days I think where we're
going to actually change this kind of
what we have here with the various
colors and this checkerboard background
we're gonna actually use some real
texture assets that people have made
willed I'll just find some one line
probably or if you guys have some you
can post them in the game engine series
discord channel I will use them and I'll
make some kind of like world and we'll
integrate that into hazel and I don't
know I think this is a really cool idea
with basically making like a little game
or at least a scene inside hazel and
that's gonna be really cool for both
having like a really solid test case
that we can actually make sure we use
all of Hazel's features so that we can
test everything and who knows maybe
we'll make this into a fun little
community game anyway thank you guys for
watching don't forget you can help
support the series on patreon patreon
Oklahoma or slash the churner is the
best way to help support me and this
series and all of that stuff
you'll get access to the more advanced
hazel development branch as I mentioned
which is like kind of a 3d version of
hazel and it's stuff that I've been
live-streaming the development of every
single week so definitely check that out
if you were interested and I will see
you guys next time hopefully hopefully
in a couple days and we'll continue
making this fun little games slash
project we've got here see you next time
goodbye
[Music]